- Hi, I'm Emily Heller,
and this is an
@midnight Master Class.
Now when I'm not entertaining,
I love to entertain.
At home, with a dinner party.
And I'm gonna teach you how
to impress your
dinner party guests.
All you need is a regular
cloth dinner napkin,
and an adventurous spirit.
(soft piano music)
You're gonna lay it
flat out on the table.
At this point, you should
maybe tell your guests like,
hey guys, I invited
Marilyn Monroe.
And they'll be like, what
are you talking about?
And you'll be like, just wait.
You're gonna grab two
corners like this,
fold them right to the
middle, crease like that.
This is a trick that
my dad taught me.
By the end of this, you're
gonna know that that's bad.
The next thing you do is you
grab the other two corners,
you fold them toward the middle.
We're halfway done, you guys.
Please don't lose hope.
Now grab the middle, right here,
and fold it up like that.
The next part, the
trickiest part,
but oh boy, is this
gonna be worth it.
Grab, with your left
hand, just the corner.
Careful not to grab the
napkin in the middle.
And connect it to the other
corner on the other side.
Same on the right,
just use your fingers.
I think that was implied.
Now, in one swift motion,
you're gonna pull them apart
and hold it against your body,
creating a brassiere.
Marilyn Monroe is
at the dinner party.
And that's gonna leave
your guests saying,
wow, this is definitely
a dinner party.
Also, cook food.
This has been an
@midnight Master Class.